[Music]
hey oh I gotta stop yelling in your ears
how are you living how you doing le FK
Oh II mean how you feeling welcome back
to the left ghost show truth be told I'm
taking a little time off not taking time
off from eating like a homies still
eating well but I am recording this the
week before you're listening to it so
I'm taking this week off for a number of
reasons one is because the next few
months me and my new lead guy David
Ingeborg gonna be traveling around the
country getting ready for the new
episode of the show that's gonna come
out this season where we're gonna do a
lot of fun stuff with NFL players so I'm
gonna take some time now so that you
know later on I got more time to burn
but I am NOT stepping away from giving
you all that good content so this week
two really good interviews with you with
two current and former Atlanta Falcons
tight ends that both of them were
awesome Algie Crumpler is such a part of
my life and he did not even realize it
from Brian Dawkins removing his soul to
the fact that when I played flag
football I always thought I was algae
Crumpler and let's just say at the end
he calls me the white algae Crumpler and
it is a moment that I will never forget
but you know me and you know that I know
how the media covers the NFL I'm not
just gonna give you an interview I need
to make sure that you know what's gonna
happen before it happens this is a
podcast that you can use so that's why
I'm gonna predict some whoa big off
seasons and to prove to you that I do
not know what's already happened I have
pulled up the illustrious website time
dot-gov Nick why don't you show them
really quick this is my dirty computer
screen as you can see Wednesday May 22nd
238 58 59 239 so he
what we're gonna do i Nick show my face
hi good to see you I have with me the
crystal ball needs to be cleaned and I'm
not gonna be able to see the future if
there's smudges all over it okay so now
yeah hold on what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna channel my focus I'm gonna use my
third eye I'm gonna stare into the
crystal ball and I'm gonna give you
three NFL storylines that I know will
happen next week and I don't even know
if it's happened yet because show the
computer screen one more time it's
Wednesday May 22nd to 39 43 44 45 back
to me okay I'm gonna stare in the
crystal ball but I need my crystal ball
music let me channel my chakra give it
to me Nick I see a vision I see a vision
out of a one of a number two maybe even
in number three I see a young backup
quarterback showing a quote live armed
that's impressing the first team Wow
could be a rookie could be a second-year
guy I'm not sure but I'm seeing the
words live arm I'm seeing the words live
arm all right let me reach out on my
chakra cue the bells again Nick okay I'm
gonna stare into this okay give it to me
all right
oh wow look at that unbelievable I see
steak
I see cheese I see no steak and cheese I
see an NFL player sharing with the media
that he has gone vegan to prepare for
the NFL season I know it's crazy I know
that you can't control it but I see it
in my crystal ball veganism no meat no
cheese like carbs vegan hood okay we
give them one more before we get to
algae Crumpler Nick okay all right this
is a big one
whoa the energy coming out of this
crystal ball right now is shocking my
chakra oh I see a fight
I see a fight between linemen I see a
fight between offensive and defensive
linemen I see a coach at the podium
standing in front of the media saying oh
that fight today it's not a distraction
it's actually a sign of fight in my team
and I wish they can control it but at
the same time it's good to see that
energy I see a fight at practice I see
the future the left go show we don't
just tell you the news we predict the
news and if you have any question about
whether or not that's already happened
show the computer screen to 40 to 20 to
40 220 to 240 223 back to me that is the
future and now a cover a conversation
without C grumbler yes and he hit the
downbeat I was not expecting this today
and this is a joy Algie Crumpler this is
my mind is melting so that song one of
our listeners rod Simba the official
music producer just made music for us
what up rock you dig it put up bad oh my
god alright so the reason this is crazy
listeners of the show of known for a
long time that I have always said that
my pro player comparison was algae
Crumpler when I play flag football or I
always thought I was a guy that could
move people and give you a little quick
shimmy and I can get to where I need to
go always wanted to know what white
Crump looked like this is me my man I am
white algae Crumpler officially made it
your career was amazing like and I'm
gonna start off with the positive and
then I'll get to Brian Dawkins later
oh I all of my passwords are Brian doc
oh that's how much were Brian Dawkins
finance Wolverine Falcons Titans year
with the Patriots what was your like
what were they saying to you when you
were coming out of college
like what cuz what was the tight end
position back then cuz right now
everybody loves to tight ends
car maybe 25 balls my senior year guys
now catching 6070 balls and completely
charged catching a lot of balls you know
I was just a big blocker play-action guy
I knew I was gonna be one of the first
three guys taken yeah I was the second
guy taken I was mad at Todd Heap Todd
who was the last pick in the range Brown
to the raid right after they won the
Super Bowl
uh-uh who was the third guy third guy I
like to bari Holloway I think you look
kind of notre dame but I was so mad at
Todd he because he wouldn't work out and
I just said if he works out he'll get
drafted earlier then I'll get drafted in
ruu so you didn't see it like if he
works out they'll realize that I can do
it better than him I just want to
first-round money mmm but I was pushed
is it better to have first-round money
or to get out of your rookie contract a
year earlier it's a little different now
oh it wasn't like that back to know I
wasn't like that back then but it's a
little different now guys had
first-round guys have that 50-year
option but they also have pretty much
the whole contract yes guaranteed so so
it's a lot different you get to Atlanta
yeah who was the quarterback in Atlanta
at the time Chris Chandler but I came in
with the rock star himself Michael Vick
same draft same draft Wow
same Drive he was one I was too and the
city was was crazy I mean it still is
crazy I like when I got through camp and
I finally got settled in and I'm trying
to go to the club I can't I just got to
sit outside away from Mike he walks in
with 20 people he's a rock star was it
from day one they want they want I mean
the energy was was bananas but Chris
Chandler was still the quarterback sure
you know it brought the team to a Super
Bowl yeah a couple yeah but when Mike
Vick shows up yeah but I mean look fans
they bought in yeah a year later Arthur
Blank bought the team he had to $10
season tickets Wow
before coming to the stadium in droves I
mean it was fun back there I didn't
realize that you are at this inflection
point of Atlanta football where that was
the chain I mean the uniforms changed
you got the new owner Vick I just
imagined to back to my amazing Madden
days
dun Duckett Crumpler and then peerless
price came a little bit later right it
came a little bit later but that one but
that middle core DVD and Crumpler was
the that was the best man it had to be
amazing to be a part of it too we ran
the football well I led the league in
rushing yeah some of those the arts came
from from Mike scrambling but kind of
hacked defences confused and when they
were confused I found a way to get open
they tended a ball and we make some
things happen what was a night at the
club that you went I didn't know that
Vic was that famous he was famous I mean
but what was the moment where you were
like wow I don't care about what
happened when I got in the club I just
didn't want to pay to get into club so I
just like Big Mike Mike hey I'm with him
yes walking in with him that era to be a
part of it yeah how do you how do you
look back on it now a lot of missed
opportunities you know I really thought
we had some good teams I thought we had
some really good teams we had some
really good players guys that played
their role really well you know if we
need it first down Brian Fenner was
gonna get it you know if we needed that
short yardage you know TJ Duquette was
gonna get it work was consistent we just
made a lot of plays and then we have
some solid guys on the defensive side of
the ball to it we just couldn't get past
that gangrene hurdle in January lost of
those guys twice in the playoffs I'm not
wearing this I didn't I didn't wear this
for the Eagles but now I am right it was
the two playoffs it was one where Brian
Dawkins at the end of one of the games
hit Mike as he was crossing the end line
yeah and I know that Dawkins has said
that was the Vick has said that's the
hardest hit he's ever taken in his life
I think that was in the vet
it wasn't the old vet to do do you
remember that hit yeah I sprained my
ankle like the first series of the game
and it was just miserable
I'm glad they tore that blew that
Stadium at the worst field ever was
cement with green paint put my hand in
the turf and be down to my wrist it was
terrible field Wow so I hated it but
they would a better team at the time but
yeah Mike I'm
like NFL Films talking about that hit
that dock has had and and I just wanted
that hit to be a little bit more famous
than the hit that he put on me let's
talk about it no we have to I'm sorry
yeah I want you to just take me through
the play logo scene slanting goes on the
outside I run the seam on the backside
Mike's supposed to hold off the safety
which he did took me a little longer to
get off the line of script
the timing was a little bit off he
throws me the ball I catch it clean my
next step never hits the ground it was
bang bang bang bang just like that and
he just caught me clean I mean even
today would have been illegal it would
have been a legal hit because he hit me
like right right in the chest laid all
the air I had don't really just
completely gone from my perspective that
felt like when the game changed like it
felt like a moment where everybody went
what did we just witness every Eagles
fan I've ever met or someone that grew
up an area says that that's explored on
the very next what happened on the next
part work done schools a touchdown
that's incredible the very next play
you're telling me your entire life
people have come up to you and be like
that's what we knew we won the game yes
but actually the next play the Falcons
scored I'm walking with Brian Dawkins
five years ago and he said the exact
same thing and I'm look at him like it's
crazy that's amazing no no I thought
that's no we didn't get a lot of yards
after you scored that touchdown Ray Ray
Ray Ray right so I can see where he's
coming from
yes but I was a little disappointed in
hearing that you get you get all the
wind in your body and your soul gone
gone so when I have I will never
experience that unless I really upset
somebody with my words which is possible
I got Terry Tate's number we can call
them Terry Tate office linebacker that's
a very good but all the wind comes out
yeah what is that process like do you
just stay on the ground as long as you
can like what what happened after that
moment when you realized what just hey
you held on to the ball - right I don't
do the ball which props to you 15
degrees outside held on to the ball I
get up I do go to the side
I'm just trying to get to the sidelines
and because we scored then I get my
energy in my air right air back so but
I've heard countless stories about that
hit and of course my man doc dis gets
inducted into the right Hall of Fame so
it gets really played again that he got
replayed everywhere I would argue that
his hit on Ike Hilliard thank you was
actually harder than your head but your
head was in the playoffs in a playoffs
and when it's in the playoffs we
remember it for a life all eyes on this
yeah and then he gave the speech after
the game well what was it like to face
doc as a huge fan of them it's honestly
it's fine I mean you want to play
against the best sometimes when you're
playing against I love playing against
guys that you know where they're gonna
be when they're supposed to be there and
that's what makes it fun that's the
chess match yeah sometimes you're
playing against guys and and they'll do
something and you're looking at him like
you weren't close to do that mmm what
are you doing why why why are you
slanting inside there's nobody outside
of you what are you doing
I had a we I had in a rout yeah you know
we got a play called and I'm running
around waist to the spot I'm going just
balls not throwing on time I know it is
either catch it and get hit yes don't
catch it and get hit so you know what it
is if I was inducting you into the love
Kosho Hall of Fame what would be your
play that you would want to play you
into the Hall like what do you believe
was your best play my best play my first
touchdown in your whole career in my
whole career so it was just downhill
after that what was the play no I called
a 60 yard seam route against New Orleans
Saints it was inaudible
so Christian Larry I'm like wow he's
gonna automotive me I'm a rookie and I
catch the ball and I'm excited and I
spiked the ball in the ball I mean it's
like Gronk spike just ball bounces into
the stands
yeah and the moment hit me I was like
man I got to get this ball back and I'm
like hey let me
get the ball and get the ball and get
the ball and all I heard was a few blows
I'm in New Orleans so I go to the
sidelines everybody's high-fiving
meeting my special teams coach curses me
out because I got to go down on kickoff
team I'm still a rookie Wow and I got a
run on the field and I'm tired so I'm
this last one down the field but they
run a reverse that comes back to me and
I make the tackle and I go vacuum what
the only reason you make that play is
because you you were loafing as you're
going I was out of breath that I was
tired so even when you make the tackle
yeah the coach is still gonna ride your
ass Dody Camillus he's still in the
league - Road mija he's a he's like a
big name - yeah the time and Tennessee
can I talk about weight as US as a
chubby guy can we talk about way do you
cool with that I'm always been a big
what was the heaviest that you play in
the NFL - 90 - 90 - 90 push into 95 my
old guys Sims was telling me that when
was it when your wife had a baby oh yeah
that's when it all changes my daughter
was born in Tennessee yeah oh yeah well
so my job in Tennessee was to set the
edge
block we had a two thousand yard rusher
yes
CJ - Kay yeah CJ - Kay and the other
word year we had the most wins in the
AFC so you guys what 14 so ends 13 13
and 3 so 4 was my role was to just clean
it out and let Bo scape go kiss just
touched it so you got to Tennessee at
what weight - 70 and then after the baby
or up to 290 easy is where do you think
that ranks all-time tight everywhere
like that I was about 275 when I was in
New England the year afterwards I don't
know my buddy Wiggs was pretty big
Jermaine Wiggins yeah he was pretty big
when he was in New England but but you
might be up there but he but he made
plays so it didn't matter you get to New
England yeah how much of a culture shock
was that I was already old it wasn't a
culture shock for me I just wanted to go
so I picked where I wanted to be yeah I
want to go somewhere where I thought but
I mean compared
the other locker rooms and facilities
how dramatically different was it it was
what I needed and wanted at the time so
awesome but the first words I think Bill
Belichick ever said was you know I'm not
an easy coach to play for but if you do
what we ask you to do you'll be fine
so worked out I had a great time fans
always think it's like it's like a game
of Thrones type of thing where you walk
in and it's like this crazy castle and
he's this like crazy ruler but every NFL
player I talked to it's amazing because
it's simple it's you do your job
yeah and that's all that matters and
there's just a lot more [ __ ] and a
lot of the other facilities I think guys
get away with more in other facilities I
think the expectations are a little bit
different when you walk through those
doors in New England and when I really
learned it weird like many camps not
many counts but workouts and I'm working
with the other quarterbacks and they're
calling the plays spread right
oh their plays are like Oh fuller out of
yada yada and that's what we're doing
and then Tommy comes in the huddle and
he's calling two plays 100 miles per
hour and everybody better be ready to go
Wow so that's when I kind of knew I say
okay I heard this is his ship I heard a
quote recently that Rodgers expects you
to be at your best but Brady will help
you get there
would you agree with that or from your
your experience there is it sort of like
you got to just catch up I don't know I
never play for a in Rogers I meant more
just I would love to have played for him
that would have been awesome what a
baller yeah that would have been awesome
I loved when they you know I was
throwing a ball to Jordy Nelson and I'm
sure Michael Finley and those guys back
in the day you know so it would have
been fun he could put it anywhere but
you know Tommy helped me I learned a lot
from him what like what kind of stuff
just just how he approaches the game and
how he demands certain things
certain players like him and Gronk they
worked on the same route after practice
every single day against the defender
the defender knew what the rot was but
they worked on it every single day Wow
until they got it right what was the
route would they mix it up the same
route
nope never met literally the play that
we saw Gronk catch in the Super Bowl
yeah
never mix it so you're telling me the
play that Gronk got which led to the
only touchdown in the Super Bowl every
single day I watched him his rookie year
do it every single how many times I
think they've done their practice 10,000
at least I mean if if he beat him in the
line of scrimmage
you know Tommy would put it over them if
he's if they're even at 10 he would put
it on the back shoulder if he's getting
stubbed he'd try to thread the needle
you know but one way or the other they
were gonna be put in their place yeah
when you saw that was there any part of
you that thought back to like your time
in Atlanta and went I wish me and Mike
did that look like and maybe you did I
don't know no I mean we had I wasn't
actually striking other guys did that we
had a great connection yeah you know on
the field you know we moved the chains I
wish we had a little bit more
consistency throughout four quarters
right always seemed like maybe you know
I would catch a couple of balls early in
the game and then the game would be on
the line and I'm yelling at a coach like
just give me the ball right just do
something we got to win this game let's
go let's go you guys just had so many
pieces you know what I mean and then
when you have that money Pete like
Roddy's gonna be like hanging out like
there were so many weapons yeah Andrade
is awesome so I had rowdy rowdy was the
complete opposite of like Gronkowski his
rookie year
you know Roddy was he was like the most
gifted talented player but he was kind
of it was kind of lazy really yeah his
second year he should have been off bro
his second year he it's like a light
bulb went off and he just took off you
know he was destroying safeties yeah and
he's blocking he was slapped in
cornerbacks running his routes he was
attacking the football ask him about it
he'll tell you those thought that's like
coming up yeah that was a drastic change
between you know rowdy
that's attitude what
that it's just you know just didn't get
it yet but he that when that light bulb
went off yes
amazing amazing turnaround Kronk is
retired yeah and I I feel like he's
gonna come back in like week ten but
let's say he's retired when he retired
everyone said greatest Titan of all time
do you agree with that I don't I don't
believe in the argument I feel like when
you have that argument there's not
there's people kind of chipping away at
you in terms of what it's like he's
great
oh of course I don't need somebody to
argue with me about Magic Johnson being
the greatest of all I think is this
Larry Bird right Ray Rice of all I take
it away from an argument and I I look at
it as the thing about Gronk that people
appreciate so much its ability to block
also like Tony Gonzalez is up there for
one of the greatest catching tight ends
of all time Kellen Winslow senior yeah
like that now we're getting into like
generational thing we're like a lot of
people these days never saw that so they
don't even know but people hear about
the blocking but they never highlight is
blocking I've never seen them highlight
grant pancake a guy but I've seen Bill
Belichick highlighted every single week
really on a Monday when we're reviewing
film you know was he how special of a
blocker was crunked very special very
special we're square I remember
scrimmage in the New Orleans Saints they
came to our practice facility and he's a
rookie just destroying some of the 8 9
10 year veterans and they are yelling at
me like Krunk get your boy get to ball
he's supposed to be doing all of that
he's like how it didn't faze groan Gronk
was going after those guys so you were
there for his rookie year was he crazy
Gronk
or was he like I don't think he's any
different now than he was it's rookie
year loving life yeah just always smile
and laughing but always attacking the
game the way he is supposed to type the
game so were there any signs early on
are stories that you were like oh no he
gets down he's a little crazy and he can
just from grabbing them and telling them
no you got a lot up over there but tell
us about it yeah
but never dropping any balls always was
blocking extremely hard his wingspan is
radius is just so big it just makes it
so much different from a time he's
throwing the ball I've also heard he's
like a football Sivan when it comes to
like remembering place is that true I
believe now yeah I believe now I don't
think that's any aspect of the offense
that he doesn't know because I've
watched him line up in every single spot
on the on the field and everybody can't
do that
no nope not at all when a player retires
are you a fan of the teams you played
for are you a fan of coaches players I'm
a fan of the players I'm a huge fan in
the Atlanta Falcons I'm a season ticket
holder are you really I go to as many
games as humanly possible that's awesome
so I love being at the old Georgia Dome
in the new mercedes-benz Stadium just
spending time with with the guys and
just just being around and high-fiving
the fame I said to see regular seats
just like everybody else yeah everybody
knows me when I walk up the steps but
when the games kicked off from watching
the game when I come down on high five
everybody kicked it in the world and
then I go back up and sit down and watch
the game did you cross over a Dirk
cutter at all I did not I you went to
Tennessee at that time yeah when I
retired I went into media a little bit
and not and I would interview cut cut
off yeah so I do know him well but I
think he'll be a good addition to the
team and in Matt be gather their
familiarity so I'm not worried about the
offense I want them to stop somebody I
look at the Falcons and I go maybe
another team who the middle of their
defense was more decimated in the last
decade than what happened them last year
Deon Jones Keon O'Neill ready to it
missed a significant amount of time I
mean great and greedy Jarrett is a name
Ricardo top five defensive interior
defensive lineman the NFL in my opinion
disrupting great he's a very good
disruptive defensive tackle yes but I
think I watched him work this offseason
with some of the things that he's
posting and I think he's going to get
better he needs to get better yes he
needs better numbers
getting after the quarterback you know
as as few years ago when you said
eighty-three times in Super Bowl we need
more I also think from that had his best
season maybe of his career other than
like the 2015 with like Kyle Shanahan I
thought last year with it all being on
him I've never seen him looked that good
physically and I've never seen him
control a game like that that's cuz you
watch the game differently you studied
the game everybody doesn't study the
game yeah you know there's 17 just but a
lot of my street cred is there's 17 19
but they really were for 19 those last
three games really just pushed their
draft stock back a little bit but him on
the move his arm strength his
decision-making like I felt like he was
like I have Sarkisian so I need to step
and I didn't mean to take that shot I
need to step my game up and I feel like
he did it well I'm like I'm today I'm
not worried about Matt at all nope I
think as he gets more comfortable
they'll continue to score more points
sure and and I just wanted to stop
people I want to stay healthy as it's
not people awesome
Algie you're the man I know that a lot
of people at home right now are go and
which one is which I'm love Co this is
algae and white algae Crumpler and I'm
allowed to say that yes yes how's your
bib list oh the spirit is within me
you're the man thanks thank you dude
appreciate it dude